ASSEMBLY GEO COMMITTEE
GOVERNMENTAL OPERATIONS
COMMITTEE. TO ORDER- GOOD
AFTERNOON WELCOME BACK. DUE TO
ONGOING COVERT NINETEEN
PRECAUTIONS WE ARE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCING IN THE
CHAMBER AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITAL. SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO
HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
PARTICIPATE IN PERSON. MASKELL
REQUIRED FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS IN
THE HEARINGS THROUGHOUT CAPITOL
GROUNDS. YOU CAN'T TESTIFY IN
PERSON VIA VIDEO CONFERENCE
FROM CAPITOL ROOM ONE TWENTY
FIVE AT THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION OR BY PHONE. THE NUMBER
TO CALL IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
TWENTY FOUR. TWO SIX TWO THIRTY
SEVEN. THIS NUMBER CAN BE FOUND
ON THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE IS
DISPLAYED ON YOUR SCREENS. FOR
THOSE CALLING IN PLEASE MAKE
YOURSELVES WELL IN THE QUEUE TO
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE.
BREES BILL HEARD TODAY THAT
WILL BE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR TWO
WITNESSES TO IN SUPPORT OF TWO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. AND
EACH TO PROVIDE TWO MINUTES OF
TESTIMONY I REPEAT TWO MINUTES
OF TESTIMONY. FOR ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES CALLING AND YOU WILL
BE PLACE IN THE QUEUE UNTIL
YOUR OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WILL BE ALTERNATED
ON THE FOLLOWING. WHEN IS YOUR
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE COMMENT
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO IN ON MEET
YOURSELF IN ORDER TO SPEAK.
PLEASE BE BRIEF. AND LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS TO YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION. AND IF YOU
SUPPORT OR NOT SUPPORT. THE
ITEM. WITH THAT WE WILL BEGIN.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. FRAZIER
HERE BIGELOW PRESIDENT. JERRY
BERMAN. BONTA. COOPER COOLEY-
DALY. DAVIES GALLAGHER. EDUARDO
GARCIA. GIPSON JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY- LOW. MATHIS QUICKSILVER.
RAMOS RIVAS. RUBIO SALAS SMITH.
CANACCORD.
WEBER WOOD SO WE
HAVE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM. HAVE
ANNOUNCEMENTS WELL FILE ITEM
TEN AB THREE FIFTY ONE HAS BEEN
PULLED BY THE AUTHOR FOR
TODAY'S HEARING. AND WE'LL MOVE
ON TO ADOPTION OF COMMITTEE
RULES WITH THEIR MOTION FOR THE
COMMITTEE RULES. I HAVE A
MOTION FROM I BELIEVE SALAS THE
END. SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO- WE
HAVE OUR FIRST AND SECOND MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FRAZIER HI FRAZIER AYE BIGELOW
AYE BIGELOW AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BERMAN. BONTA
COOLEY COOLEY AYE COOPER COOPER
I DALY DAILY AYE DAVIES DAVIES
I'D GALLAGHER. EDUARDO GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA AYE GIPSON
GIPSON AYE JONES SAWYER. LACKEY
LACKEY I LOW LOW AYE MATHIS.
QUICKSILVER RAMOS. RAMOS I
RIVAS. RUBIO SALAS SALAS I
SMITH. SMITH I. SO WE HAVE
ADOPTION OF THE COMMITTEE RULES
THIS MOVE FORWARD WILL MOVE ON
TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
MEASURES ON CONSENT MOVE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. TWELVE FIRST
AND SECOND- JUST READ THROUGH
FOR. HOUSEKEEPING AB FOUR NINE
FIVE BIGELOW. AB FIVE ELEVEN
SEVENTY BIGELOW AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE COOPER AB FOUR
FIFTY SIX DALY. AB ELEVEN FIFTY
FRAZIER AB TWELVE NINETY ONE
FRAZIER. AB THIRTEEN THIRTY
FRAZIER AB NINE FIVE SEVEN
SALAS AB ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE
SALAS IS THERE MOTION BECAUSE
THEN WE'VE GOT THE FIRST FROM
MR BIGELOW SECOND FROM MR DAILY
AMOUNT SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. FRAZIER HI FRAZIER
AYE BIGELOW AYE BIGELOW AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BERMAN. BONTA COOLEY COOLEY AYE
COOPER COOPER I DAILY DAILY AYE
DAVIES DAVIES I'D GALLAGHER.
EDUARDO GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GIPSON AYE JONES SAWYER.
BLACKIE JACKIE I LOW. LOW AYE
MATHIS MATHIS AYE QUICK SILVA
BURKE SURVIVE RAMOS. RAMOS AYE
ROBERT RIVAS. RUBIO SALAS SALAS
I SMITH. SMITH HI. HELLO MOVES
FOR WILL BE THE ROLL UPS AND
PERHAPS A MEMBERS- GONNA MOVE
ONTO OUR FIRST BILL. IN THE
COMMITTEE AB SIX THIRTY ONE
AUTHORS- MISTER BLOOM PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AB SIX
THIRTY ONE TAKES AN EXISTING
EXEMPTION THAT ALLOWS NONPROFIT
LIVE STAGE THEATERS TO SERVE
LIQUOR WITHOUT SERVING FOOD AND
EXTENDS IT TO NONPROFIT
CULTURAL FILM EXHIBITION
COMPANIES. CURRENTLY NONPROFIT
LIFE STAGE THEATERS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE GIVEN AN
EXEMPTION ALLOWING THEM TO
APPLY FOR A LIQUOR LICENSE
WITHOUT A REQUIREMENT FOR FOOD
SERVICE HOWEVER THIS EXEMPTION
DOES NOT COVER NONPROFIT
CINEMAS WHICH DEPRIVES THEM OF
THIS ECONOMIC BOOST. THAT FOR
PROFIT THEATERS OTHERWISE ENJOY
NONPROFIT CULTURAL FILM
EXHIBITION COMPANIES ARE UNIQUE
IN THAT THEY PROVIDE SCREENINGS
OF CLASSIC FOREIGN INDEPENDENT
AND RARE FILMS. THAT OFTEN
DON'T APPEAR IN MAINSTREAM
CINEMAS OR ON STREAMING
SERVICES. YOU CAN ALSO SEE THE
ROCKY HORROR PICTURE SHOW AT
MIDNIGHT. A LOT OF DON'T KNOW
WHY I KNOW THAT. SOMETIMES THEY
EVEN HOST IN PERSON Q. AND A.'S
WITH FILMMAKERS AND ACTORS FOR
EXAMPLE THE OBJECTION THEATER
IN MY DISTRICT ONCE HOSTED
GEORGE LUCAS AT THE OPENING OF
THE I. L. M. SKYWALKER SOUND
TRIBUTE FEATURING RARE ACADEMY
VISUAL EFFECTS. FROM THE STAR
WARS FILMS AS WELL AS
APPEARANCES BY BILL MURRAY
INCIPIO COUPLE AFTER A SNEAK
PREVIEW. OF LOST IN TRANSLATION.
LAST YEAR I ENTERED TO SOME
BILL AB THIRTY TO FIFTY NINE.
BUT THE BILL WAS NOT HEARD IN
COMMITTEE DUE TO COPE AT
NINETEEN. IT'S IMPORTANT TO RE
INTRODUCED THIS LEGISLATION
GIVEN THE FINANCIAL TOLL THAT
NONPROFIT CULTURAL FILM
EXHIBITION COMPANIES HAVE
EXPERIENCED SINCE THE START OF
THE PANDEMIC. PRIOR TO COPE
WITH THERE WERE ONLY FIFTEEN TO
TWENTY FIVE. SUCH THEATERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE GIVING
THESE THEATERS THIS EXEMPTION
WOULD GIVE OF THEM A LITTLE BIT
OF HELP TO MAKE UP FOR REVENUE
LOST BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC
CALLING IN TODAY'S TESTIFYING
SUPPORT OUR DENNIS BARTOK OF
AMERICAN CINEMA TEAK AND MIKE
BREWER OF THE OUTCOME OF
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE CONSULTING.
ARE YOU WITNESSES PROCEED. AS
WITNESSES SIERRA MODERATOR DO
WE HAVE WITNESSES IN THE QUEUE.
IT. WHAT'S ONE MORE TIME
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE WITNESSES
IN THE QUEUE. SOUNDS LIKE WE
MIGHT BE HAVING SOME TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES MISTER BLOOM- WE
COULD MOVE ON TO. SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION IF THEY DO COME ON
WE CAN INCLUDE THEM- AS WE GO
FORWARD IN THE PROCESS I THINK
THAT MAKES SENSE MISTER CHAIR
OKAY. SO WE'LL GO AND ASK FOR
ANY OF SUPPORT OF. IN THE
CHAMBER AS I SEE NONE. IN
OPPOSITION THE CHAMBER IS SEEN
NONE. OR ANYBODY IS IT ANY
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT IN THE
TESTIMONY STATION OR OR THE
VIDEO CONFERENCE ROOM. HARIAN
SEEING NONE. WE WILL TRY ONE
MORE TIME FOR THE WITNESSES FOR
MISTER BLOOM. MODERATOR ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN THE
QUEUE FOR THIS BILL. I DON'T
THINK OPERATORS AND- NOT
HEARING THE OPERATOR.
MISTER
BLOOM IT LOOKS LIKE WE'RE
HAVING TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES%
FROM THE LAST- COMMITTEE
HEARING IN THIS IN THIS ROOM-
AND CONNECTING TO THE NEW ONE
SO ARE WE OKAY WITH MOVING
FORWARD. WITH THE PROCESS WOULD
YOU LIKE TO RECESS AND WAIT FOR
YOUR- CALL I DON'T THINK THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WANT ME TO DO
THAT TO THEM. YES I DO WANT TO
GIVE YOU EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT OUR BUILDING H<c.cyan> YOU</c>
FEEL FIT AT PRESENT PRECIADO
THAT- MISTER CHAIR IF I COULD
MAKE A BRIEF CLOSING STATEMENT-
I'LL TAKE MY CHANCES OKAY WE'LL
MOVE FOR TO COMMIT QUESTIONS OF
ANY OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF
THE AUTHOR. WE HAVE. WE HAVEN'T
WE HAVE A LOT OF EFFORTS FOR
MOTIONS WHICH IS VERY NICE TO
HEAR IT'S A POSITIVE SIGN YES
ABSOLUTELY MISTER BLOOM WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU- YOU HEARD ME SPEAK
THIS MORNING- ABOUT A- FILM
THAT I SAW. ONLY RECENTLY THERE
WAS A DOCUMENTARY ABOUT A
STEVEN SPIELBERG. A YOUNG
STEVEN SPIELBERG WAS INSPIRED
TO BECOME A DIRECTOR AFTER
WATCHING LAWRENCE OF ARABIA- ON
THE BIG SCREEN AT A MOVIE
THEATER. TODAY THE ONLY PLACE
YOU COULD GO TO SEE THOSE FILMS
ON THE BIG SCREEN IS THAT THE
THEATERS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. THEIR IMPORTANT- FOR US
TO PRESERVE- THIS IS A SMALL
MEASURE THAT WILL HELP THEM AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM WE
DO HAVE A FIRST I BELIEVE FROM
MR MATHESON'S. INDUSTRY COOLEY
WAS THE SECOND. OR OR WHOEVER
WANTS TO BE THIRD FOURTH AND
FIFTH. SO ANYWAY WE HAVE A LOT
OF SUPPORT FOR YOUR BILL MISTER
BLOOM THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH
FOR BRINGING THIS. TO THE
FOREFRONT I APOLOGIZE FOR THE
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES IN
PLEASE EXTEND OUR APOLOGIES TO
YOUR WITNESSES WHO TOOK THE
TIME TO BE ABLE TO PRESENT-
WITH THAT GOING FORWARD MADAM
SECRETARY WE DO HAVE A DO PASS
AS AMENDED APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. IT JUST
DEPENDS ON THE RARE. YEAH. I
THINK I SAID THAT NO WHAT IS
THE BEST YOU SAID TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROACH- SO JUST
CORRECTED IT SO THAT IS WHAT I
DO HAVE A CORRECTION MY SCRIPT
DOES SAY BUT DO PASS TO APPROVE
APPROPRIATIONS- AMERICA
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL. FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB SIX THIRTY
ONE THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS FRAZIER HI
FRAZIER AYE BIGELOW AYE BIGELOW
AYE AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE BERMAN. BERMAN I BONTA
BONTA HI COOLEY. COOLEY AYE
COOPER COOPER AYE DALY DALY AYE
DAVIES DAVIES I GALLAGHER.
EDUARDO GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GIPSON HI JONES SAWYER
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY LACKEY
I LOW. LOW AYE MATHIS MATHIS
HYPERX SILVA RICK SILVA AYE
RAMOS RAMOS HI ROBERT RIVAS.
RUBIO RUBIO AYE SALAS SALAS I
SMITH SMITH I. OKAY. LOOKING
GOOD. TWENTY LIVE IT UP IN.
TWENTY LEVEL TWENTY LEAVE IT UP
THE BOOK THE BILL HAS TWENTY
WILL BE THE ROLE OPEN FOR A-
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER
BLOOM. THANK YOU. SO DO WE HAVE
THE TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES- DO
YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES MISTER
COOPER THERE WOULD BE IN THE
QUEUE. OKAY SO WE'LL MOVE ON.
OF WE WILL GET THAT RECTIFIED
VERY SOON. HI NEXT AUTHORS AB
TWENTY NINE MISTER COOPER
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST LET ME
BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
THEY MAKE THE BILL BETTER AB
TWENTY NINE IS A SIMPLE BUT
IMPORTANT BILL WITH THE GOAL OF
INCREASING PUBLIC TRANSPARENCY
A STATE GOVERNMENT ENTITIES.
THE BILL REQUIRES A STATE
ENTITY TO PROVIDE RIDINGS IN
MATERIALS ASSOCIATED WITH AN
AGENDA ITEM TO PUBLICLY SEVENTY
TWO HOURS BEFORE A PUBLIC
MEETING. ASSEMBLY TO OUR
STANDARDS MODEL AT THE SEVENTY
TWO HOUR IMPRINT WILL THE
LEGISLATURE SUBJECT TO AS A
RESULT OF PROPOSITIONFIFTY FOR
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
TRANSPARENCY ACT. WHICH NOTES
OVERWHELMINGLY WHICH I'M SORRY
WHICH VOTERS OVERWHELMINGLY
APPROVED IN. TWENTY SIXTEEN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
COOPER AS YOU STATED YOU HAVE
NO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. SO
WE'LL MOVE ON TO- AS THOSE IN
THE CHAMBER WHO SUPPORT THE
BILL. SEEING NONE ASKING FOR
THOSE IN THE CHAMBER WILL
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. SEEING
NONE. REMOVED WILL GO TO THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION
ANYBODY THE REMOTE TEST TEST
ONLY STATION. COMPONENT.
HEARING SEEING NONE WILL MOVE
ON AT THE WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCE ROOM. HEARING NONE.
MODERATOR GOING TO GO TO THE
PHONES FOR WITNESS IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION. THEY WERE STILL
HAVING THOSE TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES. MANY MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR. MISTER
COOPER WAS LIKE CLOSING YOUR
BILL. I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU MISTER COOPER HOW IT
LOOKS TO ME THAT YOU HAVE
AGREED TO WORK OF THE COMMITTEE
STAFF TO ADDRESS OF THE
FOLLOWING COUPLE OF POLICY
CONSIDERATIONS AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR WILLINGNESS TO DO SO- AS
THE MOVE BILL MOVES FORWARD- WE
DO HAVE A HOW DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS AND- MOVE THAT.
FORWARD WITH THIS VOTE- ED
SECRETARY WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. FILE ITEM FOR AB
TWENTY NINE THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
FRAZIER HI FRAZIER AYE BIGELOW.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BERMAN BERMAN I BONTA BONTA I'D
COOLEY COOLEY AYE COOPER COOPER
I DAILY DAILY AYE DAVIES DAVIES
I'D GALLAGHER REGION YOUR NEXT
EDUARDO GARCIA. GIPSON GIPSON I
JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER I
BLACKIE. LACKEY I LOW LOW AYE
MATHIS. MATHIS HI QUICK SILVA
CREEK SILVA I WROTE MOST. RAMOS
HI RIVAS. RUBIO RUBIO AYE SALAS
SALAS I SMITH SMITH I. EIGHTEEN
WITH A- WE GOT OPEN HERE. THE
BILL HAS EIGHTEEN WILL HOLD
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
AND MOVES OUT- TO
APPROPRIATIONS MISTER JONES
SAWYER. AB. ONE TWELVE SEVENTY
FIVE. IT WORKED. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS I PRESENT TO YOU
AB TWELVE SEVENTY FIVE A BILL
THAT IMPROVES ACCOUNTABILITY OF
BUSINESS LICENSES WHO SELL
MINORS WITH ALCOHOL BY BRINGING
PARITY TO THIS TESTIMONY STANDS
FOR CRIMINAL ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCEEDINGS UNDER CURRENT LAW
THE CRIMINAL TRIAL IN WHICH IT
IS ALLEGED THAT ALCOHOL WAS
SOLD OR PROVIDED TO A PERSON
UNDER AGE CAN PROCEED WITHOUT
THE TESTIMONY OF THE BINA
HOWEVER DURING THE DEPARTMENT
OF ALCOHOL BEVERAGE CONTROL
ADMINISTRATIVE HEARINGS THE
MINOR IS REQUIRED TO BE PRESENT
EVEN IF. THEIR TESTIMONY IS NOT
NECESSARY TO PROVE THE
ALLEGATIONS ARE TRUE NOT ONLY
IS THIS PRACTICE IN CONSISTENT
WITH THE CURRENT PROCEEDINGS
FOR THE SAME VIOLATION BUT
INSTANCES UP TOBACCO AND
CANNABIS SALES ALSO DO NOT
REQUIRE MINERS TO TESTIFY
ADMINISTRATIVE HEARINGS
FURTHERMORE. BECAUSE MINE IS
OFTEN FEAR CRIMINAL CITATION OR
EVEN PROSECUTION FOR PURCHASING
OR RECEIVING ALCOHOL WHILE
UNDERAGE THEY FREQUENTLY DO NOT
ATTEND MINISTRY TO HEARINGS
THIS RESULT IN THE DISMISSAL OF
ADMINISTRATIVE ENFORCEMENT
ACTION UNLESS THE SUSPECTED
LICENSEE. WAIVED THE
REQUIREMENT FOR THE MINOR TO
APPEAR UNFORTUNATELY THERE IS
NO NO INCENTIVE TO WAIVE THIS
RIGHT AND MANY LICENSEES GET
AWAY WITHOUT FACING
ADMINISTRATIVE REPERCUSSIONS
DURING TWENTY NINETEEN AND
TWENTY TWENTY AT LEAST EIGHTEEN
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED A. B. C.
ADMINISTRATIVE HEARINGS HAD
EITHER BEEN DISMISSED OR
RESULTED IN A IN A PROBE WILL
PROBABLY REDUCE PENALTIES DUE
TO NON APPEARANCE OF MINORS IF
THERE IS NO MINISTRY TO RING UP
ENFORCEMENT ACTION SUCH AS
LICENSE RED REPLICATIONS AND
FINANCIAL PENALTIES THE ONLY
MEANS LEFT FOR HOLDING
LICENSEES ACCOUNTABLE IS TO THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. WHERE
THEY WOULD FACE MISDEMEANOR
CHARGES AND POSSIBLE JAIL TIME
THIS BILL WILL STILL REQUIRE A
B. C. TO PROVE ITS CASE AN
ADMINISTRATIVE HEARING THROUGH
OTHER MEANS BUT WHAT SIMPLY NO
LONGER REQUIRED TESTIMONY IN
MINE FURTHERMORE THE DEPARTMENT
WOULD STILL. NEED TO PROVIDE
THE TESTIMONY OF A MINOR IF THE
MINE WAS PART OF A DEPART OR-
THE COR STATE. PILOT BYLINE
TEST. TO BETWEEN ADMINISTRATIVE
HEARINGS IN CRIMINAL
PROCEEDINGS AB TWELVE SEVENTY
FIVE EQUIPS THE DEPARTMENT OF
ABC WITH EFFECTIVE ALTERNATIVE
MEANS TO HOLD THOSE RESPONSIBLE
WOULD LEGALLY SELLING. ALCOHOL
TO MINORS FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE. THANK YOU MISTER JONES
ARE YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES NO
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH LEAST
NOT ON HIS PAPER. SO WHAT DOES
THE CHAMBER THAT SUPPORT THE
BILL TO SPEAK ANYBODY IN THE
CHAMBER SEEING NONE. HASSLES
THE CHAMBER IN THE OPPOSITE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL TO SPEAK
SEEING NONE. WE TO MOVE ON TO
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
THIS MORNING IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. WE MOVE ON TO THE
WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCE ROOM
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.
MODERATOR DO YOU HAVE ANY.
CALLS IN ON THIS BILL FOR A
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION. SINCE HOW
WE'RE NOT HOOKED UP TO THAT YET
WILL MOVE ON TO- ANY OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HAVE
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR. MISTER
JONES SAWYER WITH A CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. SO WE
DO HAVE A FIRST AND A SECOND
FRESHMAN MEMORY WHOSE FIRST AND
SECOND. ON THE BILL. MISTER
MATHIS WAS FIRST. SMITHSON WAS
THE SECOND THANK YOU SO MUCH-
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU MISTER
SUIT- JONES SAWYER FOR BRING
THIS BILL FORD AND CLARIFYING-
THE STATUE AND GETTING THIS.
CLEANED UP THANK YOU FOR THAT
WELCOME ASSIST GERM MADAM CHAIR
WOULD YOU PLEASE. CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB TWELVE
SEVENTY FIVE OF THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED THROUGH
APPROPRIATIONS FRAZIER HI
FRAZIER AYE BIGELOW.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BERMAN BERMAN I BONTA BONTA AYE
COOLEY. COOLEY AYE COOPER
COOPER AYE DALY DALY AYE DAVIES
DAVIES I'D GALLAGHER. EDUARDO
GARCIA. GIPSON GIPSON AYE JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY
LACKEY I LOW. LOW AYE MATHIS
MATHIS HI CORK SILVA RICK SILVA
I RAMOS RAMOS I RIVAS. RIVAS
AYE RUBIO RUBIO AYE SALAS SALAS
I SMITH SMITH I. NINETEEN
NINETY. THE BILL HAS NINETEEN
EYES WILL- THAT MOVES OUT OR DO
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE-
ROLE BEING HELD OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER JONES
SAWYER. TO MOVE ON. TO MISTER
CELIS. AB ONE TWENTY APRIL
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY. RIGHT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR
THE FIRST OF THE SECOND MOTION
THE ASSEMBLY BILL ONE TWENTY
IMPLEMENTS RECOMMENDATIONS FROM
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR AS IT
DEALS WITH THE GAMBLING CONTROL
COMMISSION RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE. THANK YOU MISTER
SALAS. FOR THAT WONDERFUL BRIEF
PRESENTATION- GIVE ME WITNESSES
A SUPPORT I DO HAVE WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT MISTER CHAIR BUT I
KNOW THAT THE PHONE LINES ARE
DOWN BUT IF NOT YOU WOULD HAVE
HEARD FROM OTHER IDEA OF THE
ANA ALKA LONG SHOT A SHE IS THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATIVE
REGULATORY AFFAIRS THE
CALIFORNIA GAMBLING CONTROL
COMMISSION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU WILL TRY ONE TIME FOR- THE
MODERATORS SEE IF WE CAN
CONNECT YOUR WITNESSES AND THEN
IF NOT WE'LL MOVE ON WITH YOUR
PERMISSION. MODERATOR IS A
WITNESS IN THE QUEUE FOR. AB.
ONE TWENTY. SEEING NONE MISSION
TO PROCEED. THANK YOU. SO WE'LL
ASK YOU OF THE CHAMBER- IS FOR
THE BILL TO SPEAK AND WE SEE
NONE IN THE CHAMBER WELL AS
THOSE IN THE CHAMBER IN
OPPOSITION TO SPEAK IN THEIR-
NO INDIVIDUALS IN THE CHAMBER.
I WILL GO TO THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION ANYBODY IN
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION
THAT WOULD LIKE TO. TESTIFY
SEEING NONE AT THE WITNESS A
VIDEO CONFERENCE ROOM ANYBODY
IN OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. PROBABLY SOME PHONES ARE
DOWN WE WON'T TOUCH THAT SO
WE'LL GO ON TO- DO ANY MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE HAVE QUESTIONS
OF THE AUTHOR MISTER GIBSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
I WANT TO COMMEND THE AUTHOR ON
BRING THIS BILL FOR- I WOULD
LIKE TO BE ADDED ON AS A CO
AUTHOR OF THE BILL. IN ADDITION
TO THAT I THINK WHAT TO THE
STATE AUDITOR THROUGH HER
INVESTIGATION AND HER AUDIT
REVEALED A LOT OF INFORMATION I
THINK WE SHOULD OF CERTAINLY
LOOK AT AND I BELIEVE THIS IS
IN A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION WITH LOOKING AT THE
INFORMATION FROM THE STATE
AUTISM SO I THANK YOU. AND
CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER GIPSON. MISTER
CELLS WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE APPRECIATED- MISTER GIPSON
WHY'D YOU WANT IS GOING. THANK
YOU SIR SO WE HAD OF FIRST FROM
MISTER MATHIS AND I THINK THE
SECOND WAS MR COOLEY. I BELIEVE
SO- I JUST WANT TO THANK MR
CELLS ALSO AND ALSO THE STATE
AUDITOR THOUGHT STATE HONORS
BEEN A GODSEND FOR THIS
LEGISLATURE. AND OUR AND OUR
ROLE OF OVERSIGHT AND AGAIN-
POINTING OUT THOSE THINGS OF
THAT WE HAVEN'T THE TIME OR
THE- RESOURCES TO DO IS SUCH AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THIS
WONDERFUL PERSON IN THAT ROLE
PROTECTING OUR INTEREST ALSO
AND- THE TAXPAYERS INTEREST.
THANK YOU TO THE TO THAT. ARM
SO WE HAVE A RESPECT FOR
SECOND- MADAM SECRETARY WOULD
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE
ITEM TWELVE AB ONE TWENTY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS FRAZIER. HI
FRAZIER AYE BIGELOW.
AGUIAR-CURRY BERMAN BERMAN I
BONTA BONTA AYE COOLEY. COOLEY
AYE COOPER COOPER AYE DALY DALY
AYE DAVIES DAVIES I GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE IN ORDER GARCIA.
GIPSON GIPSON AYE JONES SAWYER
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY LACKEY
I LOW. LOW AYE MATHIS MATHIS
III CORK SILVA RICK SILVA I
RAMOS. RAMOS I AM ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I RUBIO RUBIO AYE
SALAS SALAS I SMITH. SMITH I.
NINETEEN WILL A DIFFERENT STORY
NINETEEN WITH. THE BILL HAS
NINETEEN KIDS MOVED OUT TO HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ANY ABSENT
MEMBERS. SO WE'RE GONNA COME UP
TO OUR LAST BILL OF THE DAY- AB
TWENTY. TWO THIRTY NINE- MISTER
BILL APPROVED I'M GONNA BUTCHER.
THE SURF PROCEED THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS AB TWO
THIRTY NINE EXPANDS THE
CALIFORNIA AIR FIRST TO REDUCE
CONSUMER WASTE BY REDUCING THE
AMOUNT OF GLASS BOTTLES THAT
MAKE THEIR WAY INTO OUR
LANDFILLS AT SAINT AT THE SAME
TIME IT HELPS OUR SMALL FAMILY
WINERIES REDUCE OVERHEAD COSTS
RELATED TO BUYING NEW BOTTLES.
AB TWO TO THIRTY NINE SHOWS THE
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICIES AND
BUSINESS FRIENDLY POLICIES ARE
NOT MUTUALLY- EXCLUSIVE. SO
WITH ME TODAY HI I HEARD THAT
WERE NOT HAVING THE WITNESSES.
IS IT WELL LET ME JUST SAY
THAT- THIS IS WE DON'T HAVE
WITNESSES THIS IS REALLY DEAR
TO MY HEART DOESN'T WHITE WINE
COUNTRY HAS IN MY BACKYARD- BUT
YOU RIGHT NOW THAT WE'VE- GONE
THROUGH SO MANY BUSINESSES ARE.
LOSING IN DEN. THIS BILL HELPS
THE SUPPLEMENT FOLKS YOU KNOW
NOT EVERYONE ARAE IS MAKING IT
YOU EIGHT THEY THEY THEY LOOK
AT A WINERY THINK THAT HEY
THEY'RE THEY'RE THEY'RE THEY'RE
FULL OF BOX NOTE THERE YOUR
SMALL FAMILY BUSINESSES. AND
JUST BY ADDING THERE'S A LOT OF
FOLKS THAT HAVE SHIRTS HATS
ADDING THIS TO A SALE IT CREE
ALSO CREATES A JOB AND IT'S
ALSO- IT ENERGY GREEN BILL. WE
ARE WE ARE RIGHT NOW- TRY TO-
GET GLASS OUT OF OUT OF
LANDFILLS RIGHT NOW THIS WOULD
HELP REDUCE THIS SO I ASKED I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SIR. HELLO
WE'RE GOING TO- MOVE ON TO
THOSE IN THE CHAMBER THE
SUPPORT THE BILL TO PLEASE
SPEAK SAYING NONE. AS THE
CHAMBER- IN THE OFFICE ANY
MEMBERS OF THE CHAMBER IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL TO
SPEAK. FOR THE BILL SAYING NINE.
WE MOVE ON TO THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. HEARING
SEEING NONE. GONNA GO WITH THIS
VIDEO CONFERENCE ROOM. HEARING
AND SEEING NONE- SEE THE PHONES
ARE DOWN FOR WITNESSES AND
SUPPORTER. PROPOSITION I DO NEW
MEMBERS OF- THE COMMITTEE HAVE
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR. WOULD
YOU LIKE CLOSER THANK WHICH
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NIVEAU. SO DID I HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND MISTER
MATTHEWS AND- OKAY THANK YOU MS
MATHESON MISTER SMITH. SO-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
SUPPORTING OUR POINT IS FREE IN
THE BUSINESS SECTOR CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE IN UNPRECEDENTED TIMES
AND WE HAVE TO DO AS MUCH AS WE
CAN AND PROVIDE FLEXIBILITY SO
BUSINESSES CAN SURVIVE AND
ULTIMATELY REBOUND AND PROSPER
SO THANK YOU FOR IDENTIFYING
THIS ISSUE AND- BRINGING
FORWARD- PERRANCE SECRETARY
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
IT BUT THE PHONES ARE BACK ON
I'M GONNA PASS YOU THE PHONE
NUMBER- IN ORDER FOR THE PUBLIC
TO COLIN. SO WITH THIS WITH
THISBILL WILL LAST IF THERE
ANY. MODERATORS IS THERE
ANYBODY IN THE QUEUE. FOR A B.
TWO THIRTY NINE TO SPEAK FOR OR
IN OPPOSITION OF THE BILL. WELL
AS ONE MORE TIME MODERATOR ARE
THERE ANY. BUDDY IS THERE
ANYBODY IN THE QUEUE FOR
OPPOSITION. OR SUPPORT OF AB.
TWO THIRTY NINE. WELL. FOR ONE.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA GO THROUGH ONE
MORE TIME THE PUBLIC CALL CALL
IN LINE FOR THE- ME TOOS OR
OPPOSITION. TOLL FREE EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. WITH THE
ACCESS CODE BEING NINE FOUR
FOUR. SIX SIX FIVE EIGHT. AGAIN
TOLL FREE. 877-692-8957 TOLL
FREE. ACTING AS A CODE OF NINE
FOUR FOUR. SIX SIX FIVE EIGHT.
MODERATOR IS THERE ANYBODY IN
THE QUEUE. CONTESTA. FIVE-
SUPPORT OR IN OPPOSITION OF
THIS BILL. DURING NINE THIRTY
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM FIFTEEN AB TWO THIRTY
NINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
THROUGH CORPORATIONS FRAZIER HI
FRAZIER AYE BIGELOW.
AGUIAR-CURRY. BERMAN. BERMAN I
BONTA BONTA AYE COOLEY COOLEY
AYE COOPER COOPER AYE DALY.
DALY AYE DAVIES DAVIES I
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER I GARCIA
THANK YOU GIPSON- GIPSON AYE
JONES SAWYER. LACKEY LACKEY I
LOW. LOW AYE MATHIS MATHIS AYE
PORK SILVA. PERK SILVA I RAMOS
ALMOST I RIVAS. RIVAS AYE RUBIO.
SALAS SALAS I SMITH. THIS.
THANKS FOR YOUR- JONES SAWYER
FIVE JONES SAWYER I. SMITH
MATHAI. THEY GIVE YOU. THE
ABILITY TO MOVE FORWARD
ASSEMBLY BEEN FOR AT SOME NOW
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO LIFT THE
CALLS. BOB SECRETARY WAS GO
THROUGH THE- ROLES. THANK YOU
SIR. SO ON THE COMMITTEE ROLES
BERMAN. BERMAN I BONTA. BONTA I
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER AYE JONES
SAWYER. MATHIS QUICKSILVER.
WHEN THE COMMITTEE ROAST PORK
SILVA I. RIVAS. RIVAS AYE RUBIO.
COMMITTEE ROLES ARE OUT. AB
TWENTY NINE BERMAN AB TWENTY
NINE BIGELOW. BIGELOW I
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER AYE GARCIA.
RIVAS RIVAS I. AB TWENTY NINE
IS OUT. FILE ITEM ELEVEN
BIGELOW. EVAN IS A SUPPORT YES
HI. BIGELOW I'D GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I. FILE ITEM ELEVEN
IS OUT. FILE ITEM TWELVE
BIGELOW. BIGELOW I'M. FILE ITEM
FIFTEEN AB TWO THIRTY NINE
BIGELOW. YES. BIGELOW AYE. FILE
ITEM FIFTEEN IS OUT. OKAY. THE
NEW. ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
BERMAN BERMAN I BONTA. BONTA HI
GALLAGHER GALLAGHER AYE JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER I RIVAS.
RIVAS I CONSENT CALENDARS OUT.
WHEN WE GET. INTO ANY OTHER
OKAY. YEAH YEAH YEAH. FILE ITEM
THREE GALLAGHER GALLAGHER I. ON
THE COMMITTEE ROLLS JONES
SAWYER. JONES SAWYER I. MMHM.
BURGER CO BAKER. SOME OF THE
COLD. IN ORDER CO AND RUBIO
GIVEN BY THE- HE'S UP IN HIS-
COMMITTEE RIGHT NOW. YEAH SO
SERVICES MY QUESTION YOUR
MOTIVATIONS I WILL DEFER ON THE
MENTALITY AND I'M A QUICKLY SHE
GOES IT'S NOT ILLEGAL TO DO
WHAT WE DID IS WE MUST MAKE
SURE THE LARGE COUNCIL OF AT
HOME. WE SENT TOWERS SO WE'RE
GONNA HOLD HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR A FEW MORE MINUTES FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS VETERAN WATER
PARKS. AND WILDLIFE. AND-
LUCINTEL WE- CAN HOPEFULLY GET
THEM TO ON TO THE.
ON THE
COMMITTEE ROLES BLANCA RUBIO
BLANCA RUBIO I'M. I'M NOT
AVAILABLE RIGHT NOW. OKAY I GET
CALL FOR A WEEK FOR TOMORROW
AND ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
BLANCA RUBIO. BLANCA RUBIO I.
FILE ITEM TWELVE AB ONE TWENTY
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY I.
FILE ITEM FIFTEEN AB TWO THIRTY
NINE AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY
I BLANCA RUBIO BLANCA RUBIO I.
THE RULES. THIRTY ONE THREE SO
WE WILL DID YOU TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE WHICH YEAH OKAY. YEAH.
SO WE ROLL. I JUST HAVE ONE
MORE OFTEN. GARCIA YEAH I'M
GOING. TO SO I GOT UP AND WATER
IS GOING TO COME DOWN. YEAH
PLEASE HOLD PLEASE HAS GAVEL
DOWN HERE.
YEAH WE HAVE THE
ROLE. YEAH. ON THE COMMITTEE
ROLES EDUARDO GARCIA EDUARDO
GARCIA I. FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB SIX THIRTY ONE EDUARDO
GARCIA. EDUARDO GARCIA HI. FILE
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB TWENTY NINE
EDUARDO GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
HI. FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB TWELVE
SEVEN FIVE EDUARDO GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA. FILE ITEM
TWELVE AB ONE TWENTY EDUARDO
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA I. FILE
ITEM FIFTEEN AB TWO THIRTY NINE
EDUARDO GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA I.
THANK YOU. GOOD. LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY
GOVERNMENT A LOCAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE IS NOW COMPLETE. YOUR
JOURNEY.